TONY HAWK: I always felt
a little misplaced.
But I'd found this thing
that I loved,
and I had so much more to prove.
♪ (INSPIRATIONAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Whenever I would go,
people would just be booing.
(CROWD BOOING)
The crowd was pretty rough.
You do it weird.
He skated as if he was
being operated by a puppeteer.
(LAUGHS)
It reminded me that I can't even
fit in to the skateboard world.
But the control he had
was insane.
I was obsessed,
and I became a machine.
That was the beginning of
his launch to become Tony Hawk.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
HAWK: I was just thrust
into adulthood.
I never thought I'd be famous.
But it's the worst drug.
SPEAKER: Watching Tony learn
is more interesting
than watching him land tricks.
HAWK: I was truly alone...
and I had to go make a change.
(CROWD CHEERS)
I had not figured out how to be
a husband or father
because I didn't know
how to live in my own skin.
SPEAKER 2: Tony is
always competing against Tony.
That's all just guts.
It inspires us
to do something different.
HAWK: I'm still trying
to figure this out,
and I never wanted to back down
from a challenge.
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
I'm not gonna quit.